[Musik]
hey leute wir machen heute ein naked
kate kate's das wisst ihr wahrscheinlich
schon
das sind ja kummer sind orten wo man
außen die einzelnen lagen sie das heißt
den boden die creme boden creme und so
weiter und ich finde die total hübsch
auch für besondere anlässe
ich habe zum beispiel letztens erst zur
standesamtlichen trauung meiner
schwester ein naked zubereitet und das
habe ich euch auf instagram gezeigt und
dann habt ihr natürlich nach dem rezept
gefragt und das zeige ich euch heute und
mir ist auch total wichtig euch jetzt
von anfang an zu sagen traut euch ran
das sieht immer schwerer aus als es ist
mit ein paar einfachen tricks könnt ihr
eure eigenen naked cache backen und
jetzt gehen wir direkt über zu den
zutaten
wir packen jetzt zuerst einen leckeren
biskuitteig dafür benötigen wir ja die
habe ich hier schon getrennt außerdem
zucker und mehl speisestärke und
backpulver und vanillezucker sowie eine
prise salz
ich stehe jetzt hier bereit mit meinen
zutaten für den bizkit boden und meiner
küchenmaschine wie ist wichtig dass ich
euch vor absage das geht alles auch mit
dem hand rührt dann halt so ein bisschen
länger
was aber auch nicht schlimm ist oder wir
müssten sich für das rezept ex eine
küchenmaschine kaufen und ich gebe jetzt
zuallererst meine weiß in die maschine
denn wir schlagen eiweiß und eigelb
separat auch damit wir später schön
unter hin können und wir den perfekten
biscuit boden erreichen
das gebe ich jetzt hier rein zusammen
mit der prise salz die hilft dass die
altersstruktur schneller zerstört wird
und so sich das ganze besser aufschlagen
lässt und das lässt jetzt ca eine minute
auf höchster stufe schlagen
[Musik]
jetzt könnt ihr ganz gut erkennen dass
die masse schon richtig schön weiß und
dick geworden ist und als nächstes geben
wir die hälfte des zuckers mit dazu also
pi mal daumen ist nicht genau abmessen
denn der zucker bewegt jetzt das ist
alles richtig schön formstabil wird und
dann erhalten wir eine feste biomasse
und jetzt nochmal auf höchster
geschwindigkeit schlagen so ungefähr 34
minuten
die besen masse ist somit fertig und
jetzt müssen die schüsseln ausgetauscht
werden
den aufsatz müsste jetzt nicht unbedingt
reinigen das können durch sparen und in
die nächste schüssel kommt jetzt unser
ein gelb zusammen mit dem restlichen
zucker und dann auch noch mal so circa
fünf minuten lang richtig schön hell
cremig geschlagen
[Musik]
und ihr könnt übrigens vor dem mixen
jetzt von euer vanille zucker hinzugeben
und das könnt ihr auch austauschen wie
gesagt ich möchte lieber
zitronengeschmack dann macht also ein
bisschen zitronenschalen abreiten aber
nur von einer bio zitrone oder es gibt
ja auch ganz viele andere schöne und
leckere aromen ich habe mich heute
übernehme entschieden weil es mit der
restlichen creme super gut zusammenpasst
so jetzt wird aber gemixt
[Musik]
nach fünf minuten ist unsere eigelb
masse richtig schön hell tätig geworden
und das was wir jetzt machen müssen ist
die beiden reihe also eigelb und eiweiß
besser so müssen wir jetzt miteinander
vereinen und das machen wir mit hilfe
eines tigers wichtig ist verwendet hier
bitte kein schnee wesen denn wir wollen
ja dass die luft erhalten bleibt und das
macht ihr auch am allerbesten in zwei
bis drei schritten und wir machen das
immer so dass die b c masse zur masse
kommt
[Musik]
die baiser masse ist jetzt schön
eingerührt und jetzt bleiben wir noch
drei zutaten übrig und das sind unsere
trockenen zutaten also mehlspeise stärke
und backpulver und ich mach das mal gern
so dass ich erst mal alles miteinander
verrühren und dann in die eier masse
hinein sieben wird dann könnt ihr
nochmal sicher stehen also sicherstellen
dass alles schön 15 frei ist
[Musik]
und bei den trockenen zutaten nimmt
jetzt auch europa weiterhin und ich
mache das auch gerne so dann mache ich
lieber zwei bis drei schritte und nicht
gleich alles auf einmal damit das
gewicht die eier masse nicht unterdrückt
also nehmt euch da ruhig ganz viel zeit
für
[Musik]
und jetzt kann auch schon gebacken
werden ich habe jetzt hier eine 24 cm
springform die habe ich mit backpapier
ausgekleidet damit sie das auch später
ganz einfach entfernen können und jetzt
fühlen wir den tag hinein und dann
kommen da in den ofen
[Musik]
und jetzt kommt der teig in den backofen
ganz wichtig der muss vorgeheizt seien
auf 180 grad ober und unterhitze und
dann packen wir ihn für ca 28 minuten
richtig schön gold browser ab damit
der whisky boden muss nach dem backen
schön auskühlen und weil das hier seine
zeit dauert haben wir jetzt die zeit die
krebs zurück zu bereiten und ich habe
mich schon alles bereit gelegt ich habe
hier zum einen zimmer warme butter
die habe ich drei stunden vorher aus dem
kühlschrank genommen außerdem eine prise
salz die ist gleich für das eiweiß sehr
wichtig dann habe ich hier noch zucker
und fallen säuberlich getrennt das
eiweiß für die buttercreme verwenden wir
jetzt viele haben wir die sorge rohes ei
weiß darf man das essen wenn das ei
frisch ist dann ist es absolut
bedenkenlos zusätzlich dazu dass es
frisch ist mache ich das immer so dass
sich ist über einem wasserbad erhitzen
und dafür nehmt ihr euch ganz einfach
einen topf da kommt ganz normales
leitungswasser rhein wird ein mal
aufgekocht und dann eine große schüssel
darüber legen wichtig ist dass die
schüssel das wasser nicht berührt sonst
wäre der kontakt zu machen das wäre zu
hass und da gebe ich jetzt das eiweiß
rhein zusammen mit dem zucker und rühre
dass und so könnt ihr sicher sein dass
eiweiß ist eigentlich dann auch nicht
mehr oben er dass sieben bis acht
minuten lang schön in der hitze rührt
und alles ist bedenkenlos und schlägt am
ende wunderbar lecker
[Musik]
und noch mal ein ganz wichtiger hinweis
ihr müsst immer weitere mit einem
schneebesen wenn ihr das mal für 30 40
sekunden aus den augen lassen dann
stockt das ei und dann erhaltet ihr
spiegelei oder rührei und dann müsste
alles wieder von vorne machen
so ihr lieben sieben bis acht minuten
später haben sich die zuckerkristalle
gelöst das eiweiß ist schön erhitzt
alles ist schön warm und jetzt nehmen
wir das runter vom top gehen rüber zu
unserer küchenmaschine
wichtig ist auch hierbei dass die
küchenmaschine und der schneebesen
aufsatz richtig schön frei sind
denn sonst klappt das mit dem
aufschlagen nicht jetzt gebe ich das
eiweiß einmal in die schüssel
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt noch die prise salz mit
rein wobei prise ich würde schon fast
sagen eine messerspitze salz denn das
bewegt wiederum wir gerade auch in dem
schritt vom bis geboten dass die
altersstruktur noch schneller zerstört
wird und wie das ganze noch schneller
und besser aufschlagen können und dieser
schritt dauert jetzt auch so acht bis
zehn minuten auf höchster stufe und dann
erhalten wir wieder eine richtig schöne
diese masse
[Musik]
ganze acht bis zehn minuten später
erhalten wir eine richtig schöne
glänzende baiser masse und die ist jetzt
noch ziemlich warm denn wir haben ja das
eiweiß erhitzt und er wie die butter
einrühren muss das ganze noch ein wenig
abkühlen deshalb lasse ich jetzt so
ungefähr 30 minuten stehen und dann
würde ich erst die butter 1 und die eier
masse ist schön abgekühlt dass die
butter kann mit hinzu die butter ist ja
wie gesagt zimmer waren einfach drei
stunden vorher aus dem kühlschrank
nehmen das reicht schon
und wichtig bei der butter ist jetzt
dass wir sie es so viel weise hinzugeben
dann auf höchster stufe richtig schön
durchschlagen das heißt es dauert auch
wieder so um die zehn minuten und das
ist die buttercreme fertig
[Musik]
so meine lieben die zehn minuten sind um
die butter ist richtig schön hell cremig
aufgeschlagen und ich hab jetzt aus den
restlichen eigene die wir übrig hat von
der creme habe ich mir lemon körtge
kocht ich kann euch das bei interesse
gerne in die infobox schreiben dass die
ratz fatz es geht so schnell und ich
aromatisierte creme jetzt noch damit da
gehe ich einfach zwei esslöffeln zu was
jetzt alternativ machen könnte ist zum
beispiel konfitüre oder aufstriche alles
was der guard da habt und was ihr vor
allem gerne mögt
[Musik]
das habe ich jetzt auch nur ganz kurz
einholen lassen solange bis es sich eben
gut mit der anderen masse verbunden hat
und jetzt ist die buttercreme auch schon
fertig das heißt ich lasse jetzt auf
zimmertemperatur stehen zeigt euch ganz
kurz die zutaten für die zweite creme
und danach können wir auch schon
loslegen mit dem schichten und für die
creme füllung benötigen wir mascarpone
schlagsahne und doppel ram frischkäse
außerdem saale fest butter zucker
vanillezucker und tief gehen werden und
weil ich ja in der naked krieg so ein
bisschen abwechslung möchte und nicht
alles mit der butter creme bestreichen
möchte habe ich mich dafür entschieden
dass ich eben genau diese gräben jetzt
mache um dann die böden innen damit zu
befüllt und das zeige ich euch gleich
mit einem ganz tollen trick aber erstmal
geht an die zubereitung erklärt
dafür gebe ich jetzt alle zutaten bis
auf das sattelfest und der himmel in
meine schlüssel und verrührt das ganze
und wichtig ist es schlagsahne und co
richtig schön kalt sind am besten ganz
frisch aus dem kühlschrank
und jetzt das ganze mixen erstmal
langsam und dann immer schneller bis sie
die höchste stufe erreicht und
zwischendurch gibt er dann das
landesfest hinzu bis es komplett steif
ist
[Musik]
nach drei minuten ist die creme auch
schön standfest und wir können das ja
später sowieso noch das heißt dadurch
dass seine fest mit drin ist wird das im
kühlschrank sowieso alles noch richtig
schön fest und ich habe mich jetzt für
himbeeren entschieden die werde ich
jetzt noch unter heben wenn ihr möchtet
könnt ihr alle anderen früchten nehmen
also alles worauf wir gerade lust hat
[Musik]
und jetzt meine lieben kommt der
aufregendste teil wir schichten jetzt
die torte wir haben jetzt die cremes
zubereitet den boden zubereitet und
jetzt müssen wir nur noch den boden
durchschneiden und dann schichten fürs
durchschneiden habe ich jetzt guckt wie
hoch sie geworden ist also meine mein
boden ist jetzt sechseinhalb zentimeter
hoch das heißt ich brauche drei böden
und jeder boden soll 2 cm hoch sein
deshalb bin ich mir jetzt meinen torten
einteiler und schneidet den zwei mal
durch so dass ich drei bühnen erhalte
[Musik]
und jetzt macht ihr euch eine hübsche
tortenplatte und gibt den ersten boden
obendrauf als nächstes und das ist ganz
ganz wichtig benötigen wir einen
tortenring den wir dann drumherum
klemmen also schön eng
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt ob er
eventuell gehen springt vom rand nicht
benutzen können
davon rate ich euch jetzt in dem fall ab
denn manchmal ist es so dass ein
bodensicht nach dem backen so ein
bisschen zusammenzieht und dann wäre der
regen drum herum also der von der
springform der wälder nicht mehr ganz so
dicht und dann das nicht mehr so schön
bis jetzt habe ich hier die buttercreme
und die buttercreme dies auch von dann
tauglichkeit zu euch das fragt die habe
ich jetzt in einen großen spritzbeutel
gefüllt vorne ganz einfach die spitze
abgeschnitten und spritze jetzt ein ring
drumherum
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich hier drei buttercreme
regel übereinander gespritzt damit wir
jetzt ein bisschen platz haben für
unsere creme und man macht das
eigentlich also das mit dem buttercreme
ring das macht man um zum beispiel
torten die später mit fondant
eingekleidet werden dass die geschützt
sind vor dieser creme die ist wiederum
nicht von dann tauglich warum wir das
aber heute machen obwohl heute kein
fondant mit dem spiel ist ist einfach
zur stabilisation damit dass so ein
bisschen stabiler ist denn diese creme
ist nicht so stabil wie diese wir wollen
ja auch nicht dass später irgend ein
missgeschick passiert deshalb gehen wir
lieber auf nummer sicher und die fülle
ich jetzt hier schön in die mitte ein
[Musik]
die queen habe ich ganz kurz noch glatt
gestrichen und jetzt kommt der nächste
boden und ich mache das immer so dass
ich den boden also den unteren teil von
unserem bizkit boden als letztes nehme
weil er dann einen richtig schönen
geraden abschluss hat das heißt ich
schnappe mir jetzt ein von den zwei
anderen und zu den in die mitte und
jetzt wieder drei buttercreme ringe
spritzen und wieder mit der restlichen
kleben
[Musik]
so meine lieben das wäre geschafft jetzt
kommt der angeboten also der abschluss
obendrauf danach geht nichts mehr
geschichtet drücke das nur noch ein
wenig an und was sich jetzt als nächstes
mache ich gebe da ein bisschen
buttercreme obendrauf und verstreicht
dass es muss auch gar nicht schön
aussehen
das schützt so ein bisschen vom
austrocknen und jetzt habt ihr den
vorteil die torte ist nicht nur an den
seiten geschützt durch den tortenring
sondern auch an der oberfläche durch die
buttercreme und genau so wie sie jetzt
ist gewiss sie in den kühlschrank für
mindestens 4 stunden aber ihr könnt für
euch jetzt entscheiden macht ihr am
nächsten tag weiter so mache ich das
nämlich auch und an dem tag als meine
schwester geheiratet hat habe ich das
auch so gemacht das war total easy hat
es einen tag vorher
bis hierhin zubereitet und dann am
nächsten morgen weiter gemacht und wir
sehen uns jetzt auch am nächsten morgen
wieder so meine lieben ist ist der
nächste tag wir können unsere torte vom
tortenring befreien
tut mir nur einen gefallen fahrt einmal
drumherum mit einer winkel palette oder
mit einem tortenring messer damit ihr
das auch schön einfach anheben könnte
und jetzt seht ihr schon dass eure naked
cache entstanden ist weil man sieht er
hier schon die einzelnen schichten
jetzt geht es nur noch darum das ganze
so ein bisschen schöner einzustreichen
und zu dekorieren und dafür habe ich
hier mit etwas vorbereitet ich habe an
früchten haben wir nämlich gerade saison
erdbeeren und himbeeren
außerdem brauchen wir dicke strohhalme
und verschiedene blumen die habe ich
hier auch schon gekauft und da zeigt
euch gleich wie ihr das ganz einfach in
die torte integrieren könnt bevor wir
aber anfangen nehme ich hier buttercreme
die habe ich über nacht einfach auf
zimmertemperatur stehen lassen so ist so
richtig schön streich fest und die gebe
ich jetzt erstmal auf die oberfläche und
streicht die oberfläche damit bleibt und
dann kümmern wir uns um die seiten
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich mir zu hilfe eine
drehbare tortenplatte unterm eine hohe
tortenplatte gelegt so auf den viel
besseres gefühl und könnte aber immer
wieder hin und her drehen und ihr habt
gesehen die seiten diebe arbeiten jetzt
gar nicht viel
es gibt einmal den naked cache also
naked ist ja wirklich man jede einzelne
schicht sieht und dann gibt es noch mal
den seminar mit kate und das ist wenn
man nur so die böden noch mal so erahnen
kann ich mache jetzt um zwischending
aber ihr seht ihr wie das prinzip
funktioniert jetzt stressig hier nochmal
alles klappt bis ich zufrieden bin und
danach gebe ich ganz einfach die
erdbeeren drauf und natürlich auch die
blumen und das machen wir indem wir den
strohhalm einfach abschneiden und dann
in die torte ein stechen
[Musik]
jetzt habt ihr gesehen wie ich ein stück
aus der torte herausgeschnitten hat und
es wurden dann nicht sein ich hab ich
ein letztes mal im leben in meinen
jungen gesellen outfit geschmissen ein
letztes mal auf jeden fall ist dass das
stück was sie gesehen habt und ihr seht
jetzt schon das ist viel zu viel für
eine person also ihr könnt aus dieser
torte mindestens 32 stück heraus
bekommen und ich zeige euch jetzt auch
ganz genau wie denn dem ist sich
vorstellen auf seiner hochzeit oder
verlobung hat man nicht nur die torte
sondern auch ganz viel anderes kleine
singer brot und ein bisschen was süßes
deshalb zeige ich euch wie ich die an
schneide
dann nehmt ihr euch jetzt einfach ein
kleines stück ein dünnes stück ihr könnt
natürlich vorher auch das ganze wieder
entfernen denn fürs foto habt ihr das ja
schon da und das brautpaar hat auch
schon angeschnitten
jetzt nimmt ihr euch hier ein kleines
stück raus so sieht man es besser
dieses stück kommt jetzt zuallererst auf
eure schneide platte dann nehme ich
jetzt die hier und jetzt weil die leute
sehr hoch ist können wir das problemlos
einmal in der mitte durch teilen das
heißt in dem das stück teilt das mit
eurem messer auf eurer schneidebrett in
der mitte durch und das bekommt dann der
gast und das ist ein absolut eine große
stück jetzt im sinne von es reicht man
wird dadurch ziemlich satt aber nicht zu
voll und hat natürlich auch ganz viele
andere leckere süße dabei
und es reicht auch für alle genau man
soll sich ja wirklich auf einer
verlobung und hochzeit nicht mit einem
riesenberg an kuchen voll essen sondern
jeder darf ein bisschen was probieren
und ein bisschen was von allem probieren
und meine mein breit tupi -feld auch
schon ob das ist glaube ich ein gutes
zeichen dass ich nie wieder bei to be
sein werde sondern ich bin immer bereit
für hamza
jetzt wünsche ich euch ganz ganz viel
spaß im nach tieren dieser torte nach
dieser anleitung bin ich mir sicher ist
gelingt euch zu 100 ich werde euch in
die infobox alle genauen mengenangaben
reinschreiben 23 tipps noch die mir so
einfallen und dann kann nichts mehr
schief gehen dann falls ihr irgendwelche
fragen habt schreibt sie mir unbedingt
hier unten in das kommentarfeld
ansonsten freue ich mich über euer
feedback über ein bäumchen nach oben und
abonniert main kann kostenlos und wenn
ihr mehr solche taten sehen möchte dann
gebt mir doch gerne bescheid und ich
freue mich wenn ihr auch beim nächsten
mal dabei sein auf die die sketche
[Musik]